[Music]
YouTube listen up you know goddamn well
what I want I thought we had a deal okay
I'm calling you because I need more
booze [ __ ] you've got to have any views
you've exhausted the mics there's always
a way to milk it I'll find a way you son
of a [ __ ] I'll find a way Joe we gotta
like this
oh actually in the dick do people even
know this video is about your people
understand same amount of likes same on
my own and get the same amount of lives
as dislikes so like 500 likes and 500
discs I can we get that on the video how
do we get them to understand
[Music]
cocky little [ __ ]
same amount Alexis just snacks estoy
como dance just likes and dislikes
[Applause]
same amount of likes as dislike
[Music]
what are you gonna do next time there's
no way you can do another one I'll think
of something